la parole autochtone si c'est melissa
maulin depuis cette semaine je réponds à
la question d'un anthony qui me
demandent comment développer le
patrimoine immatériel
anthony beaucoup de gens ignorent ce
qu'est le patrimoine immatériel messi
sur le site de l'unesco
justement une description de ce qu'est
du patrimoine immatériel et ça comprend
également les traditions les expressions
vivantes hérité de nos ancêtres
transmise à nos descendants comme
traditions orales arts du spectacle
pratiques sociales rituels et événements
festifs connaissances et pratiques
concernant la nature univers
connaissance de savoir faire nécessaire
à l'artisanat traditionnel alors tu peux
comprendre que le patrimoine immatériel
c'est énorme mais comment le développer
je pense que c'est tous les jours au
quotidien qu'on va transformer nos
manières de faire et présentement je
pense qu'une des choses qu'il est plus
important c'est de conserver celui qu'on
a et qui malheureusement n'a pas été
justement protégé de façon adéquate
c'est à dire de garder les expressions
de garder des recettes des traditions
qui sont des fois moins connus moins
partagée dans les livres d'ethnologue ou
d'anthropologues mais qui font partie de
la richesse très subtil des communautés
des cultures donc comment on utilise les
poches de thé pour faire la soupe aux
castors hubei comment les cartes
porc-épic et travail est utilisé en
artisanat se sont ça fait partie des
patrimoines immatériels mais aussi des
fois les expressions qui sont nés
des stores qui sont été vécue dans des
communautés donc c'est de les
répertorier de les conserver et de
continuer à les faire avancer et
progresser dans la vie de tous les jours
c'est toi qui vont s'adapter à
l'internet qui vont s'adapter à notre
vie au travail ou 9 à 5
anthony ta question extrêmement grande
j'espère y avoir répondu correctement
mais j'espère aussi que ça va vous
intriguer sur découvrir le patrimoine
immatériel des communautés autour de vos
nos vies au village de vauville et de
vous y intéresser et de justement en les
transmettant les faire vivre
alors je souhaite une très belle semaine
j'espère que vous allez partager les
vidéos et nous envoyer des questions
avant l'automne